bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 78
sport numéro 34 allez c'est parti pour
un nouveau tour de lactus sport du
département en 26 minutes le football
américain féminin arrive à hencour après
plusieurs tentatives avorter les
Templiers viennent de créer leur section
féminine avec en ligne de mire peut-être
la participation au championnat de
France en tennis de table et en cours se
prépare à une nouvelle saison de probé
avec cette fois-ci l'objectif de monter
nous avons fait le point avant leur
premier match et nous partirons à la fin
de ce 78 sport à la découverte de la
frappe à dingue prenez un circuit d'une
douzaine de kilomètres des barbelet
électriques des tunnels remplis de bout
et vous avez le parcours du combattant
idéal et évidemment en fin d'émission
tous les résultats du weekend mais tout
d'abord on ouvre notre page de spécial
football américain section féminine des
Templiers
chaque année à hencour chez les
Templiers je crois qu'il y a une
nouveauté et cette année c'est la
section féminine et bah le pack
d'élencour est venu en ombre ce soir
avec de de droite à gauche on va
commencer par le Président George
Agostinho bonsoir à vous vous êtes
accompagné de votre fille my qui est
joueuse de la future en tout cas de la
nouvelle section féminine bonsoir à toi
Jamy CAPEN qui est donc la créatrice on
peut dire de cette section féminine et à
ta droite
l'entraîneur l'encadrant de cette
section féminine Anthony Couvin bonsoir
à tous les quatre première question qui
me vient un peu à l'esprit c'est c'est
surprenant d'avoir une section féminine
de football américain oui oui très
surprenant surtout que c'est un sport
d'homme c'est un sport de contact c'est
un sport de combat et donc du coup ça
surprend tout le monde à chaque fois
qu'on qu'on dit qu'on veut faire du
football américain ou qu'on en a fait et
comment le papa George a-t-il appris la
nouvelle quand sa fille lui a dit je
vais jouer au foot américain bien bien
surtout qu' a déjà fait plus d'un an
avec en CAD donc très bien sans aucun
problème bon ce qu'il faut dire une
petite parenthèse c'est que le football
américain il peut être un peu en France
on n'est pas tellement habitué mais
c'est quelque chose qui est
complètement dans
ouais les Allemands les Autrichiens tous
les pays de l'Est ainsi que les
Nordistes ils sont ils sont déjà des
équipes depuis plusieurs années il y a
des champions du monde des Coupes
d'Europe et tout la France on est un peu
à la traain encore une fois
malheureusement mais bon voilà donc tous
les clubs depuis de 3 ans comm commenc à
bouger puis nous bah il faut qu'on soit
là aussi quoi qu la section féminine bah
c'est un petit peu créé tout doucement
les premiers rouages tu t'es dit enfin
une une équipe de filles je vais plus
être obligé de jouer avec les garçons
oui voilà c'est vrai qu'on a fait avec J
il y a 5 ans c'est pas facile de jouer
avec des garçons donc là voilà quand m'
annoncé qu'elle voulait faire une équipe
féminine j'ai sauté sur l'occasion et
c'est une grande
nouvelle comment justement je crois que
tu as joué comme magalant étant plus
jeune avec les garçons comment ils
appréhendent justement d'avoir des
coéquipières à la place de coéquipiers
ils sont plus attentifs ou pas du tout
si ils sont plus attentifs et
contrairement à ce qu'on pense ils
étaient accueillants on est plutôt comme
des petites sœur pour eux bah maintenant
on a le même âge on est on est bah comme
leurs egoos mais au début c'est vrai que
c'était pas facile à accepter mais très
vite ça a été enfin ça a été rapide
qu'est-ce qui vous plaît à toutes les
deux dans dans le football américain
quel compartiment du jeu peut-être ça
c'est l'esprit d'équipe l'esprit
d'équipe et enfin le jeu c'est un tout
c'est un spectacle tout me plaît alors
je crois que pour l'instant vous êtes à
peu près une dizaine de joueuses je
crois on peut faire peut-être un petit
appel il y a encore des places à prendre
dans le groupe Anthony non oui ben
écoutez ça ça va très vite le football
américain on on a vite le le virusin il
suffit juste d'essayer comme Magalie l'a
déjà dit
B tout ce qui est collectif l'esprit
d'équipe le combat tout ça c'est c'est
quelque chose qui unit beaucoup les gens
très rapidement donc c'est un sport qui
se développe très rapidement donc pour
les filles ils ont ils ont en plus c tou
là ce côté fminin c'est encore plus
surprenant que le football américain
courant on s'attend pas forcément à ce
que des filles a au charbon et justement
elles y vont et donc les gens qui
viendront voir ça seront très surpris
également ouais les premis entraînements
viennent de de se faire comment ça s'est
passé il y a déjà eu un peu de contact
un petit peu de voilà de de dureté un
petit peu dans le mal oui voilà je on a
fait ça par étape donc on a commencé sur
les rudiments des petits atelier pour un
petit peu montrer l'environnement du
football américain les situations on
peut se retrouver découvrir les
différents postes et puis à partir du
second entraînement on a commencé à
rentrer un petit peu plus dans le vif du
sujet donc avec des oppositions là où ça
a été un peu plus physique et finalement
ben écoutez en plus elles se sont bien
amusé donc c'est pas mal quand on tombe
par terre et qu'on s'amuse dans un sport
c'est c'est plutôt pas mal donc non ça
s'est très bien passé effectivement
quand on commence un sport comme
celui-là le foot US il y a beaucoup de
combinaisons dans ce sport quand on est
aussi bien en phase défensive
qu'offensive c'est c'est difficile à
assimiler quand on commence voilà à 18
ans 19 ans non ça peut être ça peut être
difficile pour celui ou celle dans ce
cas-là qui ne comprend pas l'anglais
parce que tous les jeux sont en anglais
pratiquement tout est en anglais donc ça
nous permet de bosser aussi et ça peut
être difficile mais vu qu'on s'y
intéresse vraent
ça rentre tout seul en fait et quand on
est entraîneur d'une section féminine
vous qui avez connu Anthony les
championnats européens vous revenez au
templier cette année avec cette section
là on entraîne différemment un groupe
féminin non non non non pas du tout
j'entraîne pas du tout différemment le
groupe des filles je je les prends comme
à l'époque où j'encadrais des des
groupes de garçons euh d'ailleurs pour
anecdote à l'époque où elle jouait en
CAD j'étais aussi dans les encadrements
des des CAD à ce moment-là donc je les
ai vu évoluer en des effectivement aussi
euh non on on traîne pas du tout
différemment c'est la même chose en fait
on fait découvrir comme on dit ça peut
être difficile par contre en fait c'est
par étape c'est comme à l'école on
apprend par étape donc non ça ça
s'apprend tout à fait naturellement et
ça vient tout seul après on parle la
même langue la réaction des amis quelle
est-elle quand vous dites bah je joue au
foot US qu'est-ce qui se passe peut-être
chez les les amis filles on va dire pu
que elles sont surprises il y en a qui
attendaient ça parce que elles nous ont
vu jouer au match
elles ont été spectatrices donc du coup
elles attendaient juste en fait qu'on
qu'on crée le mouvement pour venir donc
c'est super alors de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique aux États-Unis vous parliez
un petit peu de cette émancipation en
tout cas cette démocratisation du du
foot US il y a une enfin la partie
féminine est bien développée et sous une
forme un petit peu
particulière ça s'appelle enfin ça
s'appelait en tout cas auparavant la
Lingerie Football League euh c'est un un
un gros cliché j'ai envie de dire non ça
ça vous ça vous met pas un petit peu en
colère ce genre de de situation là voilà
on voit à l'image les joueuxes
Américaines non non non non justement
c'est un sport comme un autre c'est on
va dire une façon de s'habiller comme
les autres comme en athlétisme comme à
la boxe et je trouve que que non c'est
enfin c'est super et justement là il va
y avoir des le championnat en fait
européen va débuter en 2015 il y a déjà
eu des sélections
son fait le weekend du 12 13 octobre oua
voilà j'y étais c'était vraiment super
il y avait ben le fondateur de la de la
Ligue LFL qui était là et c'est super il
y avait beaucoup de filles et ben
justement personne n'est choqué tout le
monde veut veut participer en fait et
côté sportif parce qu'il y a quand même
un peu un petit côté sportif là-dedans
le président qu'est-ce qu'il envisage
pour sa section féminine à l'avenir euh
nous là dans l'immédiat c'est
effectivement passé cette année de
création développ et augmenter un peu le
nombre il faud qu'ils arrivent dans les
prochains mois une bonne quinzaine voire
une vingtaine pour commencer bah les
matchs amicaux dans un premier temps il
y a quelques équipes en région
parisienne et en France qui se développe
également donc matchiko et puis je sais
que la fédé nous pousse et il sont en
train de travailler pour un futur
championnat donc êt prête dès que le
championnat de France n'existe pas
encore en tant que Senior fémininetition
ouais puisque pour l'instant il y a
vraiment deux équipes vraiment bâties en
France Saint- les sparkles et puis et
puis les sentur de Grenoble qui sont
deux deux équipes effectives he vraiment
donc c'est vrai que c'est c'est deux
équipes qui sont déjà voilà qui ont déjà
un peu d'avance qui ont déjà sont créé
déjà il y a un an ou deux donc elles ont
un peu d'avance par rapport au autres
clubs s ça non non il y a à ma
connaissance il sont bien une dizaine de
clubs aujourd'hui en France à avoir des
équipes en région parisienne il y a bien
M juste déjà en région parisienne parce
que en province on a déjà pas mal la
première équip féminine ça a été crée il
y a plutôt il y a même 5 ans ch comme ça
donc non non
c'est plus développé que que ce qu'on
croit et on n'est pas très loin d'un
championnat de France voilà ils
attendent juste encore que ça se pauine
il y a beaucoup de rencontrre amicales
les sparkles d'ailleurs que vous Avezé
juste avant ont fait un match contre une
équipe espagnole donc voilà non non
c'est ça ça se paaufine et le
championnat va bientôt arriver c'est
pour ça que nous en tant que templier on
veut on veut être prêt pour ça et vous
serez peut-être supporté par les les
cheers sur les les matchs à domicile ça
serait un beau petit cadeau
deuguration che peut-être ah c'est un
nouveau
projet l'an prochaine effectivement
merci beaucoup en tout cas tous les
quatre d'être venu puis on suivra alors
les les premiers premiers match
peut-être des des féminines des
Templiers à bientôt sur le terrain merci
en tennis de table les féminines et
longcon rest chez les féminines se
prépare à une nouvelle saison de probé
avec cette fois-ci l'objectif de monter
avec un recrutement de choix
l'intersaison une participante aux Jeux
olympiques de 2008 et une international
junior les joueus de Franck solniier
trépignent d'impatience he de rentrer
dans la compétition à domile face au
promu ici les moulinau si les sourires
sont de mise à l'entraînement les
joueuses d'élancours trépigne de jouer
leur premier match au dernier moment
deux clubs se sont désistés dans cette
poule de probé le championnat a donc
débuté à H équipes et pour l'instant le
CTT n'a pas encore jouer un seul match
alors que deux journées se sont déjà
écoulées il faut faire avec faut
s'adapter donc pour nous c'est un petit
peu dommage parce que on va débuter le
championnat très tard euh donc on attend
vraiment avec impatience de démarer
demain soir ça ça ça commence à faire
long un mal pour un bien le ctté a pu
préparer la saison sereinement et
intégrer ses recrues comme la Slovaque
et vaodorova séduite par le projet il en
courtois la 16e de finaliste au j de
2008 a quitté la proie après deux titres
consécutifs de championne de France pour
l'instant ça se passe vraiment très très
bien j'ai l'impression que je suis là
depuis depuis un bon moment et non je
viens juste arrivé donc vraiment pour
l'instant un un grand plaisir être là et
commencer la 16 an cette saison
l'expérience encadrera la jeune
audrearif à 14 ans l'international
junior est venu sur les tables des
lancours pour continuer sa progression
ça va me permettre de prendre beaucoup
d'expérience au niveau mental au niveau
jeu en plus ça parle français donc on va
pouvoir on va pouvoir bien parler parce
que moi et l'anglais ça fait deux et bah
moi je suis je suis heureuse d'être
d'être avec elle avec deux recrues de
choix et lancour annonce clairement ses
ambitions le bail de probé doit se
terminer en fin de saison
sur le papier on est l'équipe favorite
on est les plus forts maintenant faut le
faire devant la table aussi il suffit
pas de se pointer dans les salles pour
gagner c'est pour ça que j'aimerais bien
bien démarrer demain mais l'objectif
c'est de monter c'est terminer dans les
deux premiers si maintenant on gagne le
titre de champion de France de prob
terminer premier c'est encore plus beau
mais le chemin vers la montée en proie
passe d'abord par un bon démarrage face
au promus ici les
moulinau et pour ce premier match de la
saison justement les féminines de le CCT
le CT pardon ne se sont pas loupé au
Palais des Sports des cours c'est la
jeune audrearve qui ouvre le bal mais un
peu tendu l'international junior commet
trop de fautes dans ce premier match
pour finalement s'incliner sèchement 37
à 0 mais la solide Yana Nang que l'on
connaît bien et l' encour va remettre
les pendules à Z0 très rapidement sur le
même score d'ailleurs bien aidé par un
service très travaillé et une attaque de
coup droit dévastatrice et dans le 3ème
match Eva Odorova s'impose une nouvelle
fois sur le même score 37 à0 c'était le
score à la mode ce soir-là lors du
premier match et malgré quelques
premiers points crispés l'expérience de
la slovaque lui permet de remporter son
premier match sous les couleurs et l' en
courtoise et les joueurs de fransonniier
s'imposent finalement 4-2 et se
déplaceront ce ce mardi 29 octobre à
saint-enis allez on passe à notre débat
basket on va rester dans le sport
féminin mais cette fois-ci avec le
basket l'entente de le chîn et
Versailles nous étions habitués en fin
de compte à fêter un petit peu les
victoires avec vous la saison dernière
Virginie et Ophélie qui qui vient de de
rejoindre le club cette année c'est la
saison de l'apprentissage en National
une Virginie oui effectivement on
s'était rencontré l'année dernière à
l'occasion de la montée en National une
et c'est vrai qu'on était sur des séries
de victoire donc c'était plutôt positif
et cette année effectivement on doit
appréhender donc ce niveau qui est la
National une puisque même si certaines
d'entre nous nous avons déjà joué à ce
niveau c'est un nouveau groupe c'est des
nouvelles méthode de travail donc il
faut bien évidemment s'adapter et bah
acquérir de l'expérience pour pouvoir
bien évidemment gagner beaucoup plus de
matchs du moins on l'espère pour la
suite du championnat et parmi ces
nouvelles il y a il y a ophiliabé ophili
comment vous appréhendez bah ce ce
championnat de N1 dans dans un nouveau
club qui est le LCV je suis je suis
plutôt confiante enin au
départ l'entraîneur il me disait que
qu'on allait en gros qu'on allait se se
battre pour le maintien oui se battre
pour le maintien puis voir l'année
prochaine ce qu'on pourra faire mais je
pense qu'on peut quand même faire
quelque chose êreop haut de tableau pour
l'instant après 6 journées le bilan est
un petit peu négatif he il faut l'avouer
he deux victoires pour quatre défaites
on voit d'ailleurs le classement qui
s'affiche voilà vous êtes redescendu 10e
avec cette cette cette 4e défaite ce
weekend il y a pas péril en la demeure
pour l'instant on s'inquiète pas encore
du côté des de l'Entente lchen
Versailles non après ce weekend on est
allé en S placé chez les premières donc
même si on a tenu quasiment tout le
match voilà ell tiennent bien leur place
de première c'est pas pour rien après je
pense que il y a pas mal d'équipes qui
appréendent de jouer contre nous puceque
justement on a un peu un profil d'équipe
atypique et on crée la surprise depuis
ce début de saison puisque même si on
est à deux victoires et quatre défaites
chaque match qu'on a joué hormis le
premier où on perd 20 points tous les
autres matchs ça s'est joué généralement
dans les deux trois dernières minutes du
match et donc on a laissé filer la la
victoire mais enfin je pense qu'on peut
accrocher beaucoup de clubs même qui
sont classés en haut de tableau ouais
j'allais y venir Virginie justement à
chaque fois en fin de compte vous tenez
physiquement trois quartons et c'est
dans le 4e où il y a une faiblesse c'est
quoi c'est la faiblesse collective une
faiblesse physique c'est un manque de
concentration ou je pense qu'il y a
plusieurs plusieurs éléments qui entrent
en jeu la fatigue certainement voilà
jouer à ce rythme là en National une
avec des physiques beaucoup plus
imposants rythme beaucoup plus rapide
mais également voilà des mauvaises
gestions des fois de situation des
mauvais choix qui à ce niveau là ben on
le paye très très vite puisque derrière
c'est 5 10 points qu'on qu'on va
encaisser alors qu'on était juste à deux
points une minutes auparavant donc c'est
tous ces petits aspects là qu'il faut
régler à ce niveau-là après 6 journées
le collectif il est bien huilé au f ou
pas du tout c'est encore il y a encore
des petits réglages à faire parce que y
il y a quand même quelques nouvelles he
cette année il y a encore des réglages à
faire apprendre à jouer ensemble surtout
parce que on est pas mal de nouvelles et
le fait de monter en National une
sachant que la moitié de l'équipe qui
était présente au chaîné l'an dernier ét
en National 2 bah c'est c'est nouveau
c'est une découverte un petit peu du
haut niveau amateur comme on le disici
souvent de la N1 quel domaine vous devez
encore travailler peut-être un peu plus
à l'entraînement ou concrétiser en tout
cas l'entraînement en situation de match
moi je pense que défensivement on est
assez bien en place puisque par rapport
à ce que nous propose le coach on essaie
d'avoir une défense très agressive pour
justement pouvoir aller de l'avant euh
ben par rapport à ce que je disais tout
à l'heure c'est des petits détails qui à
ce niveau-là font la différence
techniquement c'est voilà des euh des
passe c'est surtout l'adresse puisqu'on
se rend compte que sur sur les six
matchs que l'on a joué on a une adresse
qui est plutôt euh pas très
satisfaisante puisqu'on est à peu près
33 % au tir ce qui est à ce niveau-là
très insuffisant euh on a laissé
beaucoup de points également sur les
lancers francs donc tous ces petits
points là ce sont en fait des problèmes
de concentration des problèmes de
rigueur voilà qui en National 2 passait
largement et nous permettait de gagner
mais aujourd'hui en National 1 il y a un
petit fossé quand même entre ces deux
niveaux donc on peut pas se permettre
d'être défaillant sur ces points là en
fait pour vous auhili à titre personnel
c'est un peu la la saison de la
nouveauté puisque donc vous êtes
international espoir depuis cet été et
donc comment vous gérer un peu tout ça
il y a un changement de vie aussi je
sais que vous avez aussi changé un peu
votre système de vie c'est compliqué à
de s'adapter à tous ces nouveaux
paramètres mais oui parce qu'avant ces
trois dernières années ben j'étais un
peu chouchoué on me faisait manger tout
ça je faisais pas mes courses puis le
fait de Ben d'habiter toute seule de
faire ses courses d'être autonome bah
c'est de plus avoir le basket au
quotidien aussi parce que là vous avez
moins d'entraînement c'est c'est plus
compliqué à gérer peut-être après une
fois être plus motivé sur le terrain
plus plus centré sur ce qu'il faut faire
le jour J peut-être non oui euh il y a
deux prochains matchs qui arrivent Renn
qui est 11e on l'a vu dans le tableau
tout à l'heure et il y a surtout
Franconville derrière qui est un peu
voilà ça va être le derby de cette
saison et qui est favori pour pour la
montée il faut une victoire sur les sur
les deux prochains matchs pour se
relancer un petit peu dans dans ce
championnat ouais je pense que déjà par
rapport à la dynamique dans laquelle on
est même s'il y a eu des défaites je
pense que déjà le prochain match à Renn
va nous permettre peut-être bah
d'engranger la victoire qui nous manque
pour retrouver un peu plus de confiance
par rapport au terrain euh et puis bien
évidemment le derby contre Franconville
qui s'annonce plutôt plutôt chaud on va
dire ça comme ça puisqu'on est quand
même pas mal d'anciens et d'ancienes don
vous Virginie voilà de francenville donc
on a la chance de les recevoir chez nous
pour le premier match donc je pense
qu'on aura déjà cet avantage là après on
n'est pas du tout dans le dans les mêmes
objectifs entre Versailles et
Franconville puisque l'année dernière
elles ont joué les play-offs en National
une et ça fait déjà quelques années
qu'elles sont à ce niveau-là euh donc
elles leur objectif clairement c'est de
finir en haut tableau et de jouer les
play-off nous c'est de jouer le maintien
donc voilà on est on y va enfin je pense
qu'on va prendre ce match sans complexe
sans complexe puisque on est censé ne
pas être dans la même cours mais après
je pense que notre combativité pourra
faire la différence très bien ben on
suivra ça alors dans les deux prochaines
journées merci à toutes les deux d'être
passé sur le set F sport et à bientôt au
bord du terrain en tout cas on va passer
à tout autre chose je vais vous faire
découvrir la frappe à dingue vous prenez
une douzaine de kilomètres des barbelet
électrifiés des tunnels remplis de bout
et vous aveit cette frappe à Ding une
course complètement de l'extrême le
parcours du combattant idéal en fait
pour les passionnés de coures déjanté
ils étaient 2300 à montaler le bois dans
les ivelines ce weekend imag d'éod moine
le soleil s'est levé il y a à peine une
heure à montaler le bois dans les
ivelines il s'amasse sur la ligne de
départ encore propre et déchaîné avant
ça
digne des entraînements de commando
d'élite les 12 km de la frappe à dingue
sont semés d'obstacles galère non c'est
génial on on est dans la boue quoi c'est
tout mais par contre là ça pique ça au
menu barbelet électrifié bain debout
encore tunnel rempli
et tout cela dans une ambiance de
carnaval né il y a 4 ans dans le Pas de
calis l'état d'esprit de la frappe à
dingue c'est l'entraide et le
dépassement de soi qui prennent le pas
sur la compétition tout le monde est
chronométré mais voilà le but c'est une
grosse déconnade on a cette
particularité d'avoir 90 % participants
sans les incités sans rien du tout qui
viennent déguiser ils savent qu'ils sont
là pour passer une très bonne journée
l'effort physique il y est parce que
c'est quand même ça reste physique et
les gars à l'arrivée vous
verrezontont quoi et quand on devient
addicte à la course d'obstacle à
l'arrivée la boue et les barbelet ne
suffisent plus un peu déçu qui est pass
assé d'eau mais sinon c'était très sympa
beaucoup trop chaud après B Gironde
c'était easy
easy on un tour je
pense trop simple et à la fin ce qui
compte c'est de l'avoir fait la médaille
de la frappe à dingue vaut bien plus que
dans les autres compétitions ils étaient
2300 à dévaler les 12 km de la cour
clinoise SALUT MAMAN je suis
là
allez on passe au résultat du
weekend avoir place au rugby 6e journée
de fédéral 3 plaisir enchaîne avec une
4e victoire consécutive les joueurs de
Philippe Béard se sont imposés sur le
fil à chartre 1514 ils consolident leur
deuxè place du coup au classement
général avec 22 points à 6 longueurs du
leader Orléan en bal 4e journée de
Nationale 2 Montini se déplace chez le
3e valdorge vous voyez cela s'affiche
les coéquipières de Gabriel parlouer se
sont logiquement inclinés he 2922 cela
ne jouait pas dans la même cours et avec
cette 3ème défaite de la saison les
inimontaines redescendent à la 9e place
au classement général avec 6 points
seulement et une toute petite longueur
d'avance he sur le premier relégable
Plouvorn en basket aucune victoire pour
les équipes livelinoises en National 3
ce weekend pour le compte de la 6e
journée trappe s'est inclinée à rouan 77
à 67 et l'entente le chîn versaill 66 à
72 à domicile face au Paris Levallois en
tir àarc ce weekend Montini accueillit
une épreuve qualificatif pour les
championnats de France de tir le cours
per le concours permettait aux archers
de se qualifier au minimum pour les
championnats départementaux voire
régionaux en cas de de bonnes performan
moyenne sur le pas de tir sur de jours
les concurrents tiré 10 volet de trois
flèches dans ces concours qualificatifs
en fait il y a toujours deux phases une
première où l'arché doit faire le
maximum de points sur ses volets et la
seconde un petit peu plus particulière
le duel entre deux
concurrents c'est différent parce que on
fait un score de qualification et après
on fait des duels donc les duels bah
c'est comme dans n'importe quel sport
tout est possible même si vous êtes a
priori sur le papier moins fort que
votre adversaire vous pouvez le battre
parce que c'est des duels et tout peut
arriver c'est un peu mental
effectivement donc tout est possible en
Requet les chocs deslancour n'ont pas pu
se changer les idées ce weekend avec la
Coupe de France pour le compte du 64e de
final les joueurs de Benjamin Ferrand se
sont inclinés plutôt sèchement face à
l'île auutre pensionnaire de National 2
la Coupe de France il faut le dire
n'était clairement pas un objectif
affiché des des joueurs éan courtois ce
match a d'ailleurs permis de faire
tourner l'effectif ce qui n'a pas
vraiment porté ses fruits avec trois
buts encaissés dans chaque mi-temps les
chocs se sont inclinés finalement 6-0 et
ils peuvent désormais se concentrer
uniquement sur leur maintien en National
2 en football il y a encore un petit
résultat 3è tour de Coupe de Paris
Versailles se déplacçer en favori sur la
pelouse de la colombienne le
pensionnaire de division d'honneur
régionale n'a fait qu'une bouchée des
Versaillais victoire 3-0 du petit
Pousset il n'y a plus aucun club
ivlinois en LCEE dans cette Coupe de
Paris encore trois petites infos avant
de passer à votre agenda tout d'abord du
football une rencontre plutôt
exceptionnel se déroule en ce moment
même au stade Guy Boniface à H encour
l'OSC reçoit le club de Birmingham pour
deux rencontres amicales de moins de 13
et moins de 15 ans dans le cadre des
partenariats avec la fondation du
parissgermain mais comme tout match he
France terre le terme amical n'en a que
le nom autant dire que les joueurs de
Birmingham sont venus à 50 ans neline
pour s'imposer résumé complet de ces
deux confrontations demain dans le 78
actu avec wifried Richi académie
moratoglo évidemment tennis une autre
info l'Académie devrait quitter les
yvelin et tiver valgrigon pour la région
de Nice depuis un an Patrick moratoglou
Le le patron de l'Académie cherchait un
site dans le sud de la France objectif
un climat qui permettrait de jouer toute
l'année en extérieur du du côté de
l'Académie on ne confirme pas pour
l'instant la formation il n'y a rien de
concret plusieurs options sont
envisagées pour rappel he Patrick
moratoglou entraîne évidemment la numéro
1 mondial Serena Williams et encore une
dernière info he si vous habitez
coignère et que vous cherchez un club de
course à pied ou de marche nordique vous
pourrez vous adresser au cap coignère
qui vient d'ouvrir son site Internet que
vous pourrez consulter au
wwwc-coère.pipfactory.com et enfin pour
terminer évidemment ce 78 sport l'agenda
du weekend ou plutôt de la semaine he
puisque ce vendredi 1er novembre c'est
la 28e édition du Grand Prix de pétanque
de la ville de Plaisir compétition en
doublette évidemment qui va se dérouler
ce vendredi je le disais première partie
à 9h au parc du château de plaisir 5e
édition du meeting national des maîtres
toute la journée c'est de la natation
les nageurs venus de toute la France
viendront s'affronter dans les lignes
d'eau de la piscine de morpa pour
obtenir leur billets pour les
championnats de France et enfin un une
dernière date le derby de la 5e journée
de la poussée de promotion d'honneur lui
en cours toujours à la recherche de sa
première victoire cette saison reçoit le
PEC ce dimanche 3 novembre au stade
Maurice Baquet coup d'envoi à 15h c'est
la fin de ce 78 sport merci encore une
fois de l'avoir suivi et n'hésitez pas à
le commenter sur les réseaux sociaux et
Twitter avec le hashtag le 78 sport tout
attaché à lundi prochain bonne
soirée